The most important piece of your AI
stack might be one you never wrote a
line off. It sits between your app and
every model you call, and the day it
goes down, every AI feature you have
goes down with [music] it. Teams are all
adding this when their AI stack grows
mature. It's the AI gateway, and by the
end of this video, you'll know exactly
what it does, when [music] you actually
need one, and the one trade-off that can
make a cheaper setup cost you [music]
more.
You usually get a gateway by accident.
On day one, your app just calls a single
model with an API key. Then, it grows.
You add a second provider because the
first one is getting rate limited. A
teammate wires the model into a second
service. Someone hardcodes an API key
into a repo, then copies it into three
more. Retry logic gets written from
scratch four separate times, slightly
wrong each time. And when the invoice
comes in, nobody can tell you which
feature spent the money. About 3 months
in, every team hits the same wall. Five
different services all talking to the
model directly without any shared logic.
One provider gets its model pulled by
the government, and half your product
goes dark with it. Lucky thing for you,
these are all plumbing problems that
were there before AI.
>> [music]
>> Regular web APIs ran into this mess a
decade ago, back when auth and rate
limiting and logging got copied, pasted
into every service until someone finally
pulled them out into one shared layer.
That layer was the API gateway. The AI
gateway is the same idea, but pointed at
models. What does this shared layer do?
Strip away the marketing, and there are
five jobs it's really there for. Most
importantly, it's a single standard way
to talk to every model. Normally, every
provider has a different request format
and its own quirks and failure modes.
The gateway hides all of that behind one
interface. Almost everyone copied the
format OpenAI shipped first. So, in
practice, you point your code at the
gateway, change one line, and swap from
one model to another by editing a
string.
Second, it [music] holds the keys.
Instead of the real provider keys
floating around your code base, they
live in the gateway. Each app gets its
own throwaway key that the gateway
trades for the real [music] one. Lose
one, revoke it, nobody else notices.
Third, it retries [music] and fails
over. When a provider throws an error or
starts rate limiting, the gateway can
retry on its own or reroute the request
to a backup model before you bother your
users with anything.
Fourth, it keeps track of everything
passing it. Every token in, every token
out, tagged by team, by app, [music] by
model. That's how you set a budget and
enforce it instead of finding out at the
end of the month. And fifth, because
every request flows through it, it's the
natural place to watch everything at
once. Latency, errors, and spend on one
dashboard.
Think of it less like a smart assistant
and more like the front desk of a
building. Everything checks in there,
gets logged, and gets pointed to the
right room. Boring and load-bearing.
Now for the confusing part, because this
corner of the industry has a naming
problem. You'll see AI gateway and LLM
gateway used for the same thing. If you
want to get specific, LLM gateway leans
developer and routing, while AI gateway
leans enterprise and governance, and now
[music] stretches to cover images,
audio, and agents. It's fine to
interchange them in most cases.
>> [music]
>> Then, there's the plain API gateway, the
decade-old ancestor I mentioned. An AI
gateway is that pattern specialized for
model traffic. Some products are
literally an old API gateway with AI
plugins bolted on. The difference is
that the AI version reads the prompt. It
understands tokens [music] and streaming
and model names where the old one just
saw web requests go by.
Two more you'll bump into. An MCP
gateway governs what an agent is allowed
to do, meaning the tools it calls, not
the model it talks to. And an inference
gateway is a lower level thing that
spreads traffic across your own GPUs.
Are you still with me?
Underneath all that, the term AI gateway
is doing two jobs at once. Half the time
it means a unified proxy that
centralizes keys, cost, and logging. The
other half it means something smarter, a
router that picks the best model for
each request. Those are two different
products wearing one name, which is
where most of the confusion comes from.
That second job, routing, is where the
real fight is. It comes [music] in two
flavors. The first is dumb on purpose
and what most production systems run.
You write the rules, send cheap requests
here, send this customer's traffic
there, and if the main model is down,
fall back to that one. It's predictable
and easy to debug. The second flavor is
smart routing, where the gateway tries
to read each prompt, guess how hard it
is, then send the easy questions to a
cheap model, and save the expensive one
for the tricky stuff. This routing is
also increasingly happening in your
favorite frontier coding harness. When
it works, the savings are real. An open
research project called Route LLM showed
you could hold around 95% of a
frontier's model's quality while sending
only a quarter of the requests [music]
its way. Everything else went to a model
a fraction of the price, and most people
couldn't tell the difference. And when
the researchers later swapped in
different models on both ends, the
[music] routing still held up, which is
a big part of why the idea gets taken
seriously.
You arrive at a catch-22. To reliably
know a prompt is too hard for the cheap
model, your little router has to
understand that prompt about as well as
the expensive model would. And if it
could do that, you wouldn't [music] need
the expensive model. The smarter the
routing gets, the closer it creeps to
being just another big model sitting in
front of your big model. It's still
useful to have since a lot of traffic is
obviously easy, and a cheap check
catches it. Just don't expect the free
lunch the pitch decks imply.
Which brings us to the trade-off I
promised, the one that turns cheaper
model into a bigger bill.
Modern AI tools lean hard on a warm
cache. When you're deep in a session
with one model, a lot of your
conversation is already sitting in fast
memory on the provider's side, ready to
reuse. So, you're not paying full
freight to reprocess it every turn.
There's another video for that if you
want to know more. Now, let a smart
router switch you to a different model
mid-conversation to save a few cents,
that new model has no warm cache for
[music] you. It has to read the entire
conversation again, cold. The one-time
cost of that reload can swallow the
savings from the cheaper model [music]
and then some. You optimized the price
per token and blew up the token count
instead. [music]
The fix is to make the router aware of
the cache. Once a model is warm, raise
the bar for switching away from it, so
you only jump ship when the savings
clearly beat the cost of going cold.
It's a small idea that plenty of naive
routers miss, and it's exactly why just
route to whatever's cheapest is worse
[music] advice than it sounds. Caching
shows up one more place. It's called
semantic caching. A normal cache only
reuses an answer if the new question is
character-for-character identical.
Semantic caching goes further. It turns
each prompt into a string of numbers
that captures its meaning, then checks
whether any past question means roughly
the same thing. Ask, [music] "What's the
capital of France?" and "France capital
city, please." and it can serve the
[music] same cached answer to both. When
it hits, you skip the model entirely.
Near zero cost, [music] instant reply.
The danger hides in the word roughly.
Set the similarity bar too loose and it
starts matching questions that look
alike but mean opposite things. Sort
ascending and sort descending land
almost on top of each other in that
number space. Match them and the gateway
hands someone the wrong answer. Pylon's
stale data where a price changed [music]
but the cache didn't, plus the fact that
upgrading your embedding model can wipe
out the whole cache without warning, and
you've got a feature that dazzles in a
demo and frays nerves in production.
Useful, but a knob to turn carefully.
Not a switch to leave on.
For all that you get out of it, the
layer costs you something, [music] too.
It adds a hop. Every request now detours
through the gateway before it reaches
the model. In practice, that overhead is
tiny next to the seconds the model
itself takes, and a well-run gateway at
the edge can even come back faster
thanks [music] to better pipes to the
providers. But on a truly
latency-critical path, measure it
yourself. The bigger issue is that
you've built a single point of failure.
Everything routes through this one
layer, so if it all falls over, every AI
feature you have falls over with it. The
thing you added for reliability becomes
the thing that can take you down. You
plan for that with backups and ideally a
code path that can skip the gateway and
call the provider directly in a pinch.
Talk about gateway-ception.
There's a trust cost, too. This layer
holds every one of your API keys in one
place. Last year, the most popular
open-source gateway, LightLLM, got hit
by a supply chain [music] attack where
compromised code went straight after
those keys. A blunt reminder that the
box holding every key is the box
attackers most want to crack. So, when
do you need an AI gateway? Plenty of
teams really don't. If all you call is
one provider from one app, call the
model directly and skip all of this. A
gateway's what you add when your
situation turns plural. A second
provider, a second service calling
models, the first surprise invoice, or
the first time someone asked which
[music] team spent all the money. The
demo everyone leads with, one key for
many models, is the least interesting
[music] reason this layer exists.
Calling a model stopped being something
one app does on its own and turned into
shared infrastructure the whole company
leans on. Once you've got multiple
models, real money on the line, and
rules about what's allowed, [music]
those concerns stop belonging in every
service and start belonging in one
place. Whether we keep calling that
place an AI gateway or it gets swallowed
[music] into the tools you already run,
nobody knows yet. It's all really young.
The job it does isn't going anywhere
because the mess it cleans up is what
you get when AI grows up inside your
code base.